ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show I'm here with an old friend
of mine I have not seen in how long
2002 the towers were up last time I
think I saw you is that true I think no
they were coming down at the end of the
conversation there was no there's no way
the towers were up no no no there's no
way 2016 18 18
I don't know I haven't seen you in a
minute but we were very close and we had
a lot of fun yes New York City yeah I'm
so happy we're still friends yes
where and it's good things are good
friendships are yes but I had a phone
number of yours for three years I've
been texting you three years I've been
texting you still not getting back to me
Tim just to find out that it wasn't your
number it was not mine and I was
consistently being like Oh if you're not
texting me back I'm gonna keep texting
you more right Tim and just being like
all right you piece of [ __ ] wait till I
see you yeah and then Mike Feeney was
like dude that's not his phone number
yeah no I would have I would have texted
you back and you have a kid now and a
wife and you're a very funny comedian
Greg Stone thanks those of you who don't
know yeah and it's good it's good to see
you you look great thanks you know I'm
diabetic I lost 13 pounds 13. very
exciting I'm hiring a trainer I'm trying
to go in that direction yeah yeah you
should get broke at Rogan we're gonna do
it
um let me train you I'm scared
get that guy that will severely damage
our relationship if I if he asked if I
have to be accountable to him yeah
that'll be the end why because he
doesn't [ __ ] around with that
he doesn't kid around like that's he's
seriously yeah I know that's what you
want I want I want a trainer who's like
yes but I also realize you there's other
things you got going on yeah like I want
that kind of trainer I want a trainer
you're gonna [ __ ] get ready but also
but also you've got you have a full
plate this new movie did you see Bros I
don't even understand I missed
everything I don't understand what it is
I I was told that I'm not allowed to see
it because I'm straight
I don't even I didn't know it was a gay
movie it's a gay movie it's a gay
rom-com and what happened it bombed
mm-hmm uh it's Billy Eichner it's
someone else I don't know uh they tried
to do
they tried to do a movie about just
dudes [ __ ] okay and America did not
come and I don't think it's in America's
homophobic because the birdcage did 185
million worldwide Brokeback Mountain was
huge but this movie for whatever reason
has done 4.8 million opening for Bros
solo that it also means many lgbtq
viewers in trouble because everyone's
gay now yeah you can't blame straight
people because if you go on the internet
everyone's kind of gay if you look at
their bios so they also didn't do see
this movie I didn't even know in there I
didn't even know what it was or existed
it was called Bros I thought it was
about bro dudes I didn't know it was
about gay guys it's about a gay guy
who's a podcaster it's about a podcaster
that's why no one wins yeah it's even a
podcaster and a dude who's kind of like
a a jock and they meet up and they're
not releasing it in the Middle East
because there's graphic sex scenes oh
really yeah there's some graphic here's
the thing with a movie like this it's
got to be so funny a movie like this has
got to be so funny that you have to be
the you know the dude to suggest it to
your other friends and not seem gay
right so the movie has to be so good
that you have to go guys you know
because it'll never be easy to do you
bring someone I go we gotta go see Bros
right there's not a laugh and it's just
men [ __ ] your friends go well now
we've learned now we've learned
something about you you've come out
thanks for telling us what you have to
do with this because it would start
where it's like you would you would
literally have to be like hey man you
know maybe go see a movie
you know it's like a bunch of dudes and
they're like they're all sitting there
and you gotta go hey man like uh I don't
know what's out you know uh
maybe uh there's something uh what about
Bros and they one of them's gonna go
isn't that the gay movie that's your
moment that's your moment you have to
hit them with bullet points you have to
be like no no no no they're like dude
aren't they sucking each other off for
two hours go no no no no it's so funny
and you know Steve Martin's in it or
whoever like you gotta have so much star
power in that one movie yeah like dude
did you see the trailer it's [ __ ]
hilarious look at the trailer like it
has to be so aggressively good so funny
just to get through you have to actually
even like or you have to like [ __ ] a
girl in the theater yes you're watching
it like yeah this is cool too you got to
be like listen I was [ __ ] my fish the
other night and you know what she wanted
to go see this movie Bros yeah and now
she's left town but I figure we're all
together right are we here we're here
maybe we'll go see Bros and and the the
thing is it's really so they've spent an
estimated 30 to 40 million to promote
Bros because it's everywhere if you look
I haven't even I know it's hard now
it's you haven't even seen any of it I
saw one sign that said Bros and it was
two guys and you know what I thought the
mugasi was about I thought about
straight guys pretending to be gay or
something I was like oh are they doing
this in 2006 like we didn't hear about
the metoo movement kind of [ __ ] real
like on woke like yeah
it's like the Sandler movie what was it
called Adam Sandler that movie where
they pretended to Get Right Now
Pronounce You Chuck and Larry and it was
like who was it was Kevin James right
even James Sandler and they pretended to
be they pretend to be because he wanted
a bang what's her name with the great
ass sorry yeah I remember the same yeah
it's my show you're not say anything you
want what's her name anyway Justin
Timberlake's ex-wife Jessica Beale yeah
so it's they pretended to be gay and
they were firemen yeah they were firemen
can't be gay
so we were thinking like I was I was
wondering it's like the marketing in
this number one the the thing Bros right
there b-r-o-s with the thing like this
you have to Market this very differently
right this cannot be marketed as like
hey everybody
it's a gay movie you have to Market this
as a [ __ ] hilarious movie where guys
[ __ ] in it like there's graphic sex in
it yeah dude sex and it's got to be so
over the top like dude sex can be really
funny but it's got to be really over the
top what's it about is it just we'll try
to get the gay sex right no I I think
it's it's about are they brothers who
are gay that might be a problem it's
about here hold on go go back for a
second Bobby a neurotic podcast host
who's happy to go on Tinder dates and
content not to have a serious
relationship that all changes when he
meets Aaron an equally detached lawyer
who likes to play the field
repeatedly drawn to each other both men
begin to show their vulnerable sides if
you go see this you are gay right you're
coming out sure like the description of
that if you're paying money to see that
movie you're gay I tell you they call it
the gay movie or the yeah you're the gay
test yeah making more money yeah Bros
was a bad name no this is this is you're
a gay movie if this was like any other
type of movie yeah where it's a guy like
me who's a garbage man in Staten Island
and who has to tell his fat wife he
sucks [ __ ] yeah and she's throwing [ __ ]
at him and calling him and she's like
you're a [ __ ] yeah that's a movie
people watch because they go and then
you can sneak in some disgusting you
know not that gay sex is just but I mean
like it should be in a comedy right gay
sex in a comedy should be funny sure
just like straight sex and a rom-com
should be funny yes like it shouldn't be
like hot no I think any sex in a comedy
should be kind of like what's going on I
would argue this though I would argue
that if you're gonna put a sex scene in
you they've yet to do this put in a real
super hardcore yeah [ __ ] scene into a
comedy come on your face I think this is
that really supposedly it's great yeah I
think it's so graphic
really people gay people aren't going to
watch this because they're turned off
how graphic your gay voice is it gay you
know like it it's okay for me for me
it's so much [ __ ] apparently and I
don't know because Billy eichers come
out and said listen you're all
homophobic you didn't go to see now
here's the thing respective Billy
Eichner you're not a big celebrity sure
you did There's Billy on the Street it's
to show people watching taxis
you what does he do right he runs around
and he's like doesn't isn't this his
show he's like hey I'm on the street
everybody and who are you I don't like
it it's very mean he's a mean guy he
walks on the street and he says hey I
don't like your hair they go why he goes
you're a [ __ ] and he leaves I'm like
this is not a show it's like a show that
legitimizes hate crimes yes you go oh
you punch that gay guy he yeah that's
what the whole show is is he chases
people on the street and make you answer
fast yeah he goes what's going on with
you you know and you're you're like I
don't know what are the three branches
of government you're like I don't really
know like yeah he's like all right you
ignorant Pig and then he just runs away
and so he's the guy so listen this let
me read a review here this is not a
movie for teens of any age it's
basically soft core porn of any age
teens of any age well Euphoria which is
the biggest show on TV [ __ ] great and
it's a great show I love that I've
always wanted to be in that as some
unimportant I'll edit you in thing can
you yeah I don't understand a man we'll
just do some scenes and I'll put you in
it now you're in it I've always wanted
to just so I could like stand next to
jack up a lordy and just be like it's
another day on the you know it's another
day for guys like us you know just
something stupid but it's softcore porn
right it's a very like see now this goes
it's not a movie for somebody by the way
brought their teens to Bros and is very
very angry about this some parrot said
we're going to Bros I don't know how
that happened they walked in and they're
like we're going to brows yeah this is
not a movie for teens of any age it's
basically softcore porn why would you
let your 16 year old watch a movie with
fairly graphic orgies gay or straight
are standards for what is considered
appropriate entertainment for teens has
reached a new low I don't know if this
was marketed to teens and then the next
person under because hilarious and
raunchy
I'm gonna go see this movie and see if I
get some lift it's very exciting for me
yeah I don't know what's going on here I
don't know how graphic it is it doesn't
matter yeah I mean let me tell you this
after you get married yeah ever you
become gay you become everything I am I
am it's like prison you know people go
to prison you have to forget right I
will [ __ ] anything yeah and I'll do and
and I watch these things I try to test
myself to see where I can go sexually
what I can watch I'm gonna go to this
movie
just and I'm gonna try to jerk off yeah
see what happens I love this article it
goes Bros review Billy Eichner won't
play nice for the straights it's like
why is everything
so angry I know
it's annoying it's like why is
everything so just
make a really funny movie and sneak some
graphic right sex into it I knew when I
would try to get my friends to watch gay
stuff it always had to have something
else going on that's gay stuff give me a
hint like a movie
like what's a gay movie
just give me I need to try to think of a
good uh gay movie
bird cage yeah brilliant right Nicholson
May one of the funniest scripts ever
written right you easily go dude it's
[ __ ] it's actually really funny yeah
okay
you know Twilight is gay very gay very
good yeah but it's you know it's the guy
with the shirt it's like yeah you gotta
have some other you got to have like
yeah but there's a hot chick in it
because there's a lot of you gotta
Target the market of closeted people yes
they want to see the movie closeted
people want to go to see the movie some
of them are gonna go see it alone it's a
gay movie with a different hook it's a
different hook you gotta be able to
because there's got someone's got to be
able to sit through this movie fully
erect and walk out a straight man with
their friends and if that doesn't happen
you failed as a producer here's what I
do I open a business I open a theater
where the theater our whole vibe is we
tell you every movie sold out except the
gay movie so you go hey let's go see the
new Transformers interesting right you
walk up you go two three four for
Transformers and they go sorry yeah all
we have is uh raping ass sex for four
hours and you go well we already paid
for the Uber and now you're in now
you're in right well I want to see the
lesbian version of this right the
lesbian version of this where I don't
know what they would call like how
extreme is it gonna get they just call
it dykes
and it's just two women on like a farm
in Wisconsin just eating each other's
[ __ ] for two hours yeah and again I
understand America's homophobic people
say homophobic [ __ ] about me all the
time you know it's the least bad of what
they say about me but I understand that
the country's homophobic but you got to
see it as a challenge just work around
it right just work around it but also
like
yeah okay the country's homophobic but
the major markets aren't they're not New
York L.A homophobia is not the reason
for this failure that's what I agree the
reason for this failure is it's probably
not funny like yeah sorry can we watch a
trailer on this or will we get totally
[ __ ] like I mean I don't mean like we
can watch a trailer right why are you
looking at me I'm a guest I don't know
let me throw this at you you also have
to understand that if they would have
marketed as there's all this gay sex
scenes yes you're also going to get the
Bros who are like Yo dude let's go watch
that gay movie yes I mean those guys are
gonna go see it as a bit you know
because they think that's funny you have
to allow them right space to ironically
yes go see this bro movie Let's Hear It
Let's watch this hey guys it's Bobby
Lieber coming to you from the future
home of the lgbtq plus Museum see you
ready I'm out they're talking about the
lgbtq museum
this happens to be bisexual awareness
bisexual Awareness Week
lesbian history month was in March
nobody said a goddamn thing of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week
[Music]
this is habitat too I mean he's great
he's done great stuff situation you're
in a trouble
let me tell you what's Progressive now
being alone I love my life I love my
freedom I love my Independence that's
kind of sad that I don't want to be in a
throuple I don't even want to be in a
couple
Bobby I had sex with that 65 year old
Jesus he's ripped I don't know it's like
they injected steroids into Dumbledore
oh my God that's not it
right you know when you a line like that
it's like they injected steroids into
Dumbledore yeah that's not it okay good
comedies were like 10 years ago yeah I
mean like Will Ferrell the [ __ ] those
like movies the Adam McKay that genre
was like dude that [ __ ] was so we're
done you could have snuck in hardcore
anal into Step Brothers no one would
have cared I would I would have loved it
it would have been fine yeah because it
was so [ __ ] funny you put a fisting
scene in the middle of Tommy Boy fine
I I'll say this I'll throw this out to
your fans edit a hardcore sex scene into
Step Brothers right let's see if it
makes it better yeah I guarantee it does
right I guarantee it's just Larry
steenberg and getting plowed yeah yeah
the two brothers right Bros it's about
step Bros and they're [ __ ] re-edit
Steph Bros line through step and just
edit hot sex between Will Ferrell yeah
and Philip Seymour Huffman what's his
name uh John C Riley yeah that Phillips
Robin has died of heroin overdose
that'll happen very sad very sad this is
what happens well my whole feeling on
the whole thing is I hate blaming
homophobia I think you just gotta do
better [ __ ] right but I also understand
that like there is that's real to a
degree where people just go yeah it's
hard for a dude to suggest to his
buddies let's go see Bros
but we got to think about like first of
all the title right the title right Bros
is stupid it's a dumb type because some
guys gotta say to a guy in a pickup
truck you want to just go see Bros
[Laughter]
title
the truck have had a day already and
they're just going I mean none of this
is working out yeah let's just go see
Bros let's go see Bros do you want to
see that guy suck off that other guy I
mean I'll check it out yeah I mean it's
it's a wild moment because gay sex or
getting more views I think honestly I
think they didn't go they didn't go far
enough yeah they didn't go far enough I
think they went too medium that whole
trailer was medium right they go pull
back or go all in oh go all in all in
yeah all in I'm in yeah which is or it's
eyes wide shot with Billy eichman the
most annoying person on television
people do not react to him the way he
thinks people react to him well those
respect like he doesn't he doesn't come
off like a fun guy you want to spend two
hours with no he hates me I don't even
know him he I know he hates me I think
he blocked me on Twitter I'm not sure
but he hates like so a lot of people in
the movies not fans of mine because it's
like I get it whatever you know I'd be
one of them call me a pet homosexual
once because I was just friends with
Rogan in them what does that mean it
means like I'm friends with straight
people let me say this though yeah these
guys maybe this is disrespectful yeah 99
of the time I forget you're gay that's
true not in like whatever but yeah he
would say they would say that I'm doing
the wrong thing because they would say
that I'm trying to assimilate into the
straight World instead of walking around
spitting Comet people
that's what that's what they would say
instead of me because for me it would be
weirder if I went harder to get like
that would be just as disingenuous right
if I got on stage I was like hey [ __ ]
right stop it like that would be strange
and I would argue too I want to just I
forget you're getting the way I bet
people forget I'm Italian that's right
you know what I mean like yeah it's a
giant part of my life yeah but there's
just so you don't walk around with a
full-blooded Italian shirts no you don't
talk about the mother country no it's
just not you've got other things going a
lot of things going on man yeah but
that's a great example because it both
gay people and Italians have become
insufferable in similar ways and equally
greasy and equally kind of greasy and
they have a they fuse in many ways but
it's just it's having real prod like if
you ever listen to an Italian from Long
Island they'll tell you that they've
been discriminated against
worse than anyone it's like yeah no but
every movie is about you guys love them
you love it we love being a cartoon
disown it and you can't walk away from
it like gay people love promiscuity they
love the idea that they're always
[ __ ] then you can't get mad if people
then associate you with that Italian
people love being a cartoon and they are
a cartoon and we lean into being a
cartoon that's right it is a while it is
a we you yeah you call me hey we [ __ ]
scream across the street we love being
Super Mario but then in someone else we
call the lead we call the you know the
Anti-Defamation League yeah are you
actually familiar with why the
Anti-Defamation League was started I
have no idea the Anti-Defamation League
is was when people would do [ __ ] on
Italians you call them they were they
were created to tell to let people know
that the mob doesn't exist they were
created by the mob to discredit people
who went after the mob is that true yes
yes the mob created the league so that
when people said Italian under the mafia
they would sue them that's like a lot of
pedophiles created something called The
False memory syndrome like the false
memory Foundation like a lot of kids
were being like we were abused the false
memory syndrome Foundation was like
actually these are memories that were
implanted in their head by a
psychologist and that was created by
pedophiles there was this guy from the
CIA on the board of like the false
memory syndrome Foundation oh she's very
weird it's funny it's like Italian
starting the ADL to just tell people hey
don't worry about it yeah don't worry
you're talking [ __ ] but it's not even
real right this thing you're mad at
doesn't exist which is so stupid idiots
yeah also Bros black screen that the
trailer should have been full black
screen yeah cut to
69ing right just a full 69 yes and then
people would see that movie and then it
just say see it [ __ ]
Pros we've had enough you make that
trailer yeah people go see that movie
yeah but that's people do get mad you
know there are people that say to me
like you you assimilate into and you say
to yourself you're like what are you
supposed to do what do you suppose what
would you because you remembered me in
New York City I had jokes about being
gay but it wasn't 10 of them right I had
one or two of them right and they were
fun you know one of them was about
killing myself on the George Washington
Bridge I had to say about ice cream yeah
you know it was but it wasn't like this
every single thing right right like
there are Comics now where it's like to
get on stage and you're like so I'm
queer and the audience will clap which
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
weird to me because it's like what is
this what's the next level what's the
Deep Earnest of it great you're gay but
give me the like I was hoping with this
movie it was like it was going to open
my eyes to some [ __ ] I didn't know about
but I watched that as a straight man I
go yeah I get it I see this yes you're
neurotic and annoying I get it I know a
woman who's like a Pakistani lesbian and
you know what it all comes down to she
likes hats
she just wears baseball hats you'd think
being a lesbian with that background
would have like a fat should be a
fascinating person she just loves
putting on hats she loves sneakers a
high Beast there's no difference between
her and a 15 year old who's waiting
outside to get a new pair of shoes that
are dropping there's nothing wrong with
that but it's like not everybody's thing
doesn't come from their like life
experience right no I get it like being
Italian has meant what to you I mean
it's the food it's the culture no but
there was a distinct thing in my career
where I went I'm Greg corluzzo I'm from
New Jersey is that true yeah my stone is
my mom's name coraluzo is my dad's name
so you were Greg corluzzo before you
became Greg Stone yep and my first joke
was did you eat did you eat G and I went
Greg if you go this road if you continue
to do this joke you will be the Italian
comedian from New Jersey tell the joke
and you yeah oh no no please you have to
tell Greg carluzzo oh you have to tell
the joke the joke was so it's so bad
it's not a good joke it's okay it's not
not that's why I'm asking you to tell it
it's like so we're Italian right Italian
people we like to take it's like we
every word is what it's like oh every
sentence is one word so go g g i call my
dad I go what does it mean to slow it
down and go g g did you eat it was like
a bunch of that [ __ ] I I am I am going
to kill myself for saying this out loud
I buried that person but you you regret
carluza did you dress differently no I
mean I used to wear no I but I knew I
wouldn't do this yeah I wear a tracksuit
okay you wore it in the beginning no no
no I'm kidding okay uh but like I knew
that if I kept doing these Jersey gigs I
was doing a lot of [ __ ] weddings I
was doing a lot of like vfws I went you
are going to make a lot of money these
people love what you're doing you know
if I did Italian you get you get the
polio container in your freezer every
all the references they [ __ ] loved it
and I went you you got to be better than
this and I and I buried Greg coraluza
when I started in Long Island you can
only imagine yeah the amount of people
that were Greg carluzzo yes
I'm talking about 19 year old 20 year
old kids where Greg carluzzo like they
were like hey are you doing they get on
stage
uh it was so gross I mean I did a party
once a private party where I got up and
I I it was Four Bridges which is the
school like Billy Joel's kids went okay
it's a private school and it was an
Islip and it was in a nice backyard in
Long Island and there was like a John
Travolta impersonator
who told me he goes yeah I used to do
comedy is what I do now and he got on
stage you know the white outfit and he
was doing Saturday Night Fever yeah and
he's like come on Grandma like you try
to get the old lady up he goes come on
Grandma let's go and the old woman has
kind of gone back and forth and you
could see him he's like really in it and
he's doing it and he's like and you
could just see like the pain that was
buried so behind his eyes and I'm like
well it makes sense because it's not
that much of a leap right from Greg
carluzzo oh to if you're gonna be that
guy you then it's like well why wouldn't
I put on a leather white leather outfit
and dance in someone's backyard to a
movie that came out 30 years ago 30
years ago that's the thing too he's
probably still doing Travolta and like
it's like these Trump guys yeah who are
probably they're still out there doing
Trump Impressions and it's still there
in 15 years they're still doing Trump
Impressions I knew a guy up recently who
was doing bush
yeah still doing George like Trump I
think is still fine he's still out there
I knew guys doing bush like recently wow
in fact I did uh uh and listen this
comedian's a legend I'm I'm blanking on
his name right now and everyone's gonna
be like no you're not you're selling out
this is how it happened
uh no but he's a [ __ ] lad he's an old
Jewish guy Rob something he had the
first HBO special I'm literally blanking
on his name uh this guy
from Larry Richard Lewis no another but
another guy he likes that you got it
though yeah no I know what you where
you're going Ron Klein yes Robert Klein
and he did and he's you know that guy
was a killer but he did I did a count
lines and he was doing kind of Clinton
Lewinsky jokes we're talking
sure 2015 2016. because it was just like
and you know and it's that [ __ ] happens
dude I I saw a guy it's Scotty's
Steakhouse tell people about and I don't
want to I'm not trying to [ __ ] on the
sure thing of Scotty's Steakhouse tell
people about Scotty's Steakhouse and
comedy Cove well he says well I will
tell you the comedian I saw there yeah I
want to say
maybe 2017. shout out to Scotty's
Steakhouse shout out to Scotty I'll be
back there in a few years it's what
happened yeah on the way up on the way
down I've never been there but I'll be
back nothing like when someone gives you
a menu at a comedy club and goes you
can't order these things yeah it just
it's just keeping you no meat no meat
you can enjoy yourself with some penne
we're watching our money yeah we're
watching the bottom line yeah don't get
cute
um and the comedian did he goes knock on
dead he starts doing Ross Perot and I
watched he goes now I gotta do it and he
was like can't can't and I'm I'm going
what the [ __ ] Ross Perot and I pull as a
feature I'm like we gotta Google this
one this is 30 years Russ Perot I see
this kid in a crowd going people didn't
know who lost Perot was then people
don't yes yeah like it was hard then
yeah audiences would be like what's
going on not getting there
is that rust Pro or bush one I guess
it's Ross Pro no wait Ross Perot was
here's little say no right because bush
that sounds like Dana carvey's Bush one
I think you're right and I can't
remember have a [ __ ] there's a whole
Subterranean road yeah well continue
there's a whole Subterranean level of
Comedy that people don't understand and
it's birthday parties bachelorette
parties there's a site called gig
Masters where gig Masters yeah you put
your stuff up there and you can people
hire you oh we want a comedian and it's
not a comedy club it's not a theater you
show up to a house I did one of these
gigs where we the whole gig was we had
to pretend to be a band and then start
telling jokes and it was in Lodi New
Jersey and there was this one armed
crackhead who ran a recovery Comedy
Company that I used to work for and he
goes you'd be perfect for this and I go
why he goes you can go with the flow and
we got in a car and we went there we had
to pretend to be this bad band and then
the whole bit was
oh we're not a band we're we're actually
comedians let me tell you how badly that
flopped
let me tell you how no one was
interested at all yeah in the fact that
we weren't a band yeah at all and then
we had to after that didn't land we had
to go okay well now we're doing the
comedy show and then somebody had to get
up and go hey everybody remember that
like saying you're a steakhouse yes and
then being like Oh just kidding we're
vegan right but it's like we have a lot
of people who came here for some steak
right you know it's a band I'm excited
for a band oh but now you're a shitty
comedian everybody wanted the band yeah
people were so excited when the band was
setting up
nobody wanted to go to play Nobody wants
like comedy everybody's like are you
doing sweet Caroline like we were taking
requests people were shouting requests
going hey Google do this one they were
like oh great just got a band The Look
on their faces when we start because we
got to remember one guy is one arm right
wait he's got one arm that he lost he
said he lost it in Vietnam but he didn't
he lost it shooting up sure and me and
then these two other
one guy who had a little bit of a career
but didn't and like said something crazy
in the car Like Comics will say crazy
[ __ ] like he said he goes yeah he goes
yeah Jon Stewart's got all he's got but
can he do Biloxi Mississippi and you go
yeah I'm sure by the way I'm sure he
could I'm sure he could fill it sure and
what who cares why would he want to
comedians have these crazy ways of
justifying whatever they've you know and
we we go there and this guy is also his
bit was it he was he does a Chinese
accent but he's not I know that comedian
so he does half the acting like
and then in the middle of it he goes
stop [ __ ] around I'm really not
Chinese
I you know that I know that man and I
worked with him at Scotty's Steakhouse
and does he it's still the thing right I
mean I saw him maybe seven years ago and
he did it in a time when it should not
have been done right he goes up there
and he goes wine like he pretends to
fully be trained yes
I have a horrible thing yes
and he goes and there's nervous laughs
don't you say that the whole time and
the guy yes
oh wait a minute are you saying this is
a white guy and does an Asian joke no no
he's an Asian guy I don't know it's kind
of it's ambiguous it's ambiguous no he's
Asian okay I don't know I know another
guy who does something else he's a white
guy you know a white guy yeah who does
the Chinese accent and then says oh no
I'm not so no because my memory is
[ __ ] and I'm an idiot he does an
entire joke where he's just doing this
Chinese accent right and then the twist
is that
you know I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened here whatever it was maybe
pretend to be Irish was probably wrong
it was probably it was bad it was bad
but he's doing a Chinese I know there's
a white guy out there doing a Chinese
accent that is wild yeah no it's it's
the things we used to see in Long Island
like the levels of inappropriate like I
listen I hate all the like people that
are too welcome to you know sure but the
things we saw right the levels of racism
and comedy that I that's why I don't get
like when people like a lot of people
that I know in La be like this is so
inappropriate I'm like you have no idea
you've never seen it you have no idea
what I've seen you don't know what's out
there you don't know what people will
get on a stage and do you've never seen
the vulgar firemen it was like Joey the
vulgar fireman who goes out there and he
goes I just call it like I see him and
he goes That's all black
I'm not even kidding he was saying he
does all the [ __ ] VFW gigs man yeah
we had all those guys in Long Island
like the mailman yeah
I like that type of guy who's like pick
up your [ __ ] mail I know it's EBT
you're like Jesus Christ what is wrong
with you yeah you ever watched Dr dirty
though I do find him actually really
funny have you ever seen Dr dirty I know
he's alone
he is very by the way he's inappropriate
but he's very funny yes yes it's very
funny he I mean he's does some crazy
[ __ ] out of control
does his ticket size Footers in Tampa he
goes Obama care how many [ __ ] signed
up for Obama care and he's playing the
piano I signed up for it I love it and
in Tampa they're going wild yes and it
is it is I mean listen it is fun at the
gang bang he thought that gang bang song
at the gang bang oh it's great I don't
give a [ __ ] because he has one where he
goes like this he goes I [ __ ] the food
he's talking about Thanksgiving he goes
because like my family's rude and I [ __ ]
the food all right that's undeniable you
can't get mad at that no you can't get
mad at that that's what Bros should have
been right what if prose was just gay
gays being racist which we all know they
can be right gays can be racist [ __ ] not
me but what if Bros was just gentrifying
gay guys on the citizen app going
complaining about you know the turn
things are taking
you see that movie that might have been
fun that might have been fun just gay
racist they were too worried I think
they were too worried in this movie to
go all in they should have went all in
well things now have to be you know
ridiculous I think things have to be
crazy so I think that like when you're
doing a movie things have got it they
gotta rise to the time so the times are
so crazy we just got out of this
pandemic and it's crazy and Trump was
the president like you got to put out a
movie that's [ __ ] nuts right the
trailer's got to be so over the top
crazy the people literally have to go I
can't believe they made this I gotta get
to this theater I cannot before they
take it out yeah if if people aren't
going I can't believe this was made
right they're not gonna go see it with
Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a language lesson so the
reality is everybody wants to speak
another language I always wanted to
other language learning apps use AI for
their lesson plans but Baba lessons were
created by over 150 language experts and
voiced by real native speakers not
computers I don't know if natives a term
probably uh with Babel you could choose
from 14 different languages including
Spanish French Italian German uh plus
Babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent there are so many ways to learn
with Babel in addition to lessons you
can access podcast games video stories
and even live classes plus it comes with
a 20-day money-back guarantee start your
new language learning Journey today with
Babel I'm telling you everybody needs to
learn multiple languages we don't know
who's going to win these wars call to
action right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
Tim that's babble.com
b-a-b-b-e-l so you can get 55 off your
subscription you start learning another
language you'll learn it in no time
you'll be better than everybody else go
to babel.com Tim for up to 55 off your
subscription Babble is language for life
we want to welcome a new partner to the
show Underdog fantasy you heard about
these guys there's a brand new fantasy
sports company just launched in 2020.
they're the fastest growing Sports
company of all time they're investors
and Q include Mark Cuban Kevin Durant
The Chainsmokers Nas kygo Odell Beckham
and their latest fundraise was led by
BlackRock those are the people buying up
all the houses that you cannot afford
point is they made it very simple and
easy to win up to 20 of your money in a
single night this is not as hardcore or
nerdy as a typical fantasy sports game
if you're just a casual fan you've got a
chance to win big just pick higher or
lower on your favorite player stats get
them all right and you win it's that
simple and they're gonna match your
first deposit up to a hundred dollars
when you use promo code Tim support the
show support the billionaires at
BlackRock go to underdogfantasy.com and
deposit now with the promo code Tim and
one win 20 20 times your money tonight
that's underdogfantasy.com and deposit
now with the promo code Tim and win 20
20 times sorry 20 times your money
tonight that's underdogfantasy.com
deposit 100 and use promo code Tim this
is so much fun everybody I know does it
they all win money we all love it it's
fun it's fast it's easy it's cheap it's
real it's important it's it's gay it's
straight it's trans it's beautiful it's
old it's young black white brown it's
indigenous all the things that it needs
to be do it no discrimination here just
a lot of opportunities to learn money
earn money earn money not learn money
earn money earn money and I gotta say
they gotta stop with this like because
it's clear that people it didn't fail
because people were homophobic I think
but it's like but that's not going to
make me see it more that's gonna make me
hate you more you know people that kind
of see it because they knew there was
too much [ __ ] in this movie now I'm gonna
go yeah I'm gonna go see the come movie
why did so many people watch Two Girls
One Cup right no one really jerks off to
that no but you've got to see it it's a
novelty it's a novelty yeah show me the
come movie I say I think that's what
else is going on with you besides gay
movies
you have a child does that does that do
you
do you automatically love them
it's drugs yes you do it's not real love
it's drugs you're it's Evolution you
want to [ __ ] try drugs Evolution that
keeps humans alive you love them in this
level that is I'm a creep like I stare
at him when he goes to sleep they're
amazed he exists I'm I kiss him on the
lips I'm not gonna give a [ __ ] I just
like if you're unless it exists it's
weird but I mean love I wish my parents
felt that I'm sure they did for a period
of time in their defense they're
probably like yeah no one thinks that
little baby becomes a podcaster and
talks [ __ ] about us for seven years
right that tests anyone well that's the
kind of thing reasonably me now having
this kid this is probably too serious I
kind of started looking back and being
like Oh man my stepdad used to beat the
[ __ ] out of us and I was just accepting
that as normal would you ever hit the
kid no never no no you just you don't
would Greg carluzzo yes do you dropping
right in the face well that's what I
mean do you ever think of you slip back
in a car if the kid's acting up you slip
back in a car loser you're like now
you're getting [ __ ] up
and will you threaten I'm like that will
you be like Greg carluzzo shitty
comedian New Jersey hack is gonna come
out here and I'm gonna hit you and then
maybe Mom let me tell you this Greg
Caruso looks at his kid and goes you
think you're better than me yeah and
then just jams him up my father punched
me in the face once I was in a backyard
I had ditched school for I don't know it
wasn't cute anymore sure it wasn't cute
right my father I was with my friend
Shay I don't want to say his last name
but it is very funny so I want to kind
of say anything with Shane mcgoulihan it
was Irish it's fun and we were sitting
there and we were best friends we were
smoking pot and we were high but the
type of high where it's worn off and
it's you just feel heavy and it's not
and you can't react yep and we see my
father's tan Mazda Navajo approaching
and we run
we run into a yard and my father chases
us into a yard and I stand up and I went
hey what's going and he doesn't say
anything he just decks me in the face I
fall down uh a guy comes running the
door and he's like get out of here and
then my dad puts me in the car and
drives me to the beach and just like
screams at me in the car he's like
you're driving me [ __ ] nuts did you
skit school again
probably right so it didn't work that's
right punch in the face doesn't work I
dropped out of Community College yeah
you should have
he should have pulled over and go do you
want to be me right like he should have
pulled over and go I'm in a Mazda Navajo
he goes let me tell you how your life's
gonna work yeah take a look at me I'm in
this [ __ ] car you're a piece do you
want to be you know that that might have
been more effective I'm so happy you're
pulling up a Navajo pull up the Mazda
Navajo oh still looking good tan ten
yeah I love my dad he was a good dad and
I deserved that beating Right Punch
wasn't it they didn't have the tools
they didn't know how they'd have Google
that was exactly my father's car right
there is exactly the car he jumped out
of and punched me in the face
still moving yeah what which what can
you get that for now you could get that
for about 300 bucks
for you later I mean it just might be
fun to have it yeah because we were so
afraid of that car when you're high and
you're a young kid and you're running
around town you're terrified of your
parents cars my friend's mother had a
green Taurus the Chinese food delivery
guy also had a green Taurus we were so
happy when it was not her it was him and
look I'm an idea man so you just gotta
listen to this yeah get rid of the desk
put a Navajo you sit in the Navajo and
that's where you do the interview from
listen the show is evolving maybe I mean
that might not be the worst idea I just
steering wheel the whole time I
broadcast from a Mazda Navajo I don't
know this guy's had a full mental break
I mean it's the worst case scenario what
you're out what 600 bucks yeah it's not
the worst idea 1500 right now yeah but
you talk that guy 1994 Navajo my
father's exact car 1600 by the way you
get that
easily 500 bucks yeah cash yeah 500
bucks you get a miles an hour but what
are the tools now instead of hitting the
kids it's never been articulated to me
what the tools are that you as a parent
would utilize well I'm I'm my kids one
so I haven't used any of them yet well
of course but like but like I could say
the tools we have Google right right so
I'll tell you this with the [ __ ] with my
one-year-old uh I'm looking things up
like I almost just gave my kid honey the
other day and my wife was like what are
you doing don't Google it and I googled
it you give the kid botulism how the
[ __ ] would I know that who would know
who would know that you just you just
hope to God back in the day like all
your kids teeth hurt put whiskey in
their mouth yeah it's like you just hope
to God that you had neighbors who were
smarter than you and a lot of people
didn't I'm maybe thinking maybe I'll
adopt a kid but it's so hard I know this
straight couple trying to adopt and they
can't like I'm thinking maybe down the
line maybe down the line I'd want to you
know this straight couple they can't
adopt every time they go to the end of
the process and the the original Parent
school we actually wanted back I know
who you're talking about this is
heartbreaking this is heartbreaking
heartbreaking and we it's the same
people were talking about and it's
really sad so for me it's like it's got
to be difficult
to go through that entire process and
then at the end have somebody go
actually
we want I think you should adopt like a
like a slightly older kid some kid who's
someone with a problem yeah I think
you're the perfect dad for someone to
like yeah to lose like oh this kid's
smoking pot in third grade you're like
well now Tim Jones my dad yeah and yeah
that's a fan that'd be hilarious that
would be great yeah they're all filmed
mentally well
but it's it's when can you when does
adopting stop
we have one we have six months together
to make this work yeah no I mean I would
love to get adopted now I was I hung out
with some I would have met some
billionaire a few months ago yeah and I
was on his boat and I was like dude I'll
be your kid I know you know what he
would have never paid attention to you
that's how he made a billion dollars
unless he inherited it in which case it
would have been aloof and weird and he
still would not have paid attention I
think he's now that he's got the money
he's kind of slowing down he's he's
realizing he's like that's what happens
right I realize it I'm like yeah we've
done well I've made a lot of money but
you look at your life and you go oh I
wish I had more relationships with
people that I've let fall by the wayside
right for sure you pick him up and pick
them up we're too late you ever try to
answer this guy it's hard hard to pick
it up no it's not old for sometimes it
is
sometimes sure sometimes anything's
anything sometimes it's hard call
someone to pick it up what do you want
to pick up call a friend yeah it's true
what are you doing yeah I'll be happy to
hear from you yeah everyone I know who
knows you actually knows you yeah loves
you well that's sweet so yeah eat my ass
yeah yeah perhaps you know what I mean
yeah I was so happy to hear from you no
for sure and then the thing too I even
felt bad because then you were like you
want to come to the Pod and I was like
man we could also just
wanted to see how you're doing you know
yeah well you know I mean well this is
great too this is awesome it matters
this is the same thing yep we have the
same conversations maybe more slurs
maybe more things that YouTube couldn't
get you know but it's the same type of
thing are you worried about the economy
you have a kid now and everybody says
you can get up articles about this
everybody says that the economy is about
to free fall into some type of like this
is all the financial people are like on
YouTube they're like the economy's about
to experience some type of Free Fall
that we've like never seen the economy
money none of that ever means anything
to me because I was born broke that's
right live broke
I know how to be broke I like that I'll
be broke again you know I mean now I got
a little bit of money right and I'm like
ah this is perfect this is great I'll be
all right you know what I mean I just
need to make a little bit more money to
pay for daycare but now that's what
sucks with cat before I have my kid it
was like this is just like whatever but
now it's like I love but I love this
article ready is it a great article here
this is the title brief recession or
complete economic collapse what these
Wall Street veterans think it's so great
yeah brief recession or complete
collapse which one death or torture
because there's probably people that are
saying one and then there's other people
in the article saying the other brief
hey brief recession complete collapse
let me ask you this Elon Musk yeah
four against this guy I never know I
here's what I'd like I like a lot of
things about him I think he's a little
bit of a Carnival Barker I think he
likes Fame I've said that on Joe's show
I think he likes starting the pot
um I don't think anyone's going to Mars
in our lifetime I just don't believe
that yeah uh there was these tunnels he
was gonna build everywhere to make
traffic better I don't know where they
are but I think big picture idea wise I
liked it he likes Free Speech there's a
lot of things about him that I really
like Madam he's fun he's done you know
he's a nice guy like I was in a New
Year's thing I had no business being at
wow you bet Elon Musk yeah he's a really
smart guy right brilliant guy but
there's there's part of them where I I
kind of relate to part of him which I'm
like maybe I shouldn't because I'm a
comedian oh right so there's a level of
me that looks at him and go oh we kind
of want a similar thing well I'm like
that's not great yeah like I think he
likes a little bit of the
having fun right he likes a little bit
of the attention and I don't know yeah
yeah yeah you're too powerful for that
you could change the world so big and
powerful but I do think
broad Strokes good right but little
everyone has peccadillos some
billionaires throw uh kids into a
volcano
he wants people to laugh at his tweets
it's it's not the worst yeah by the way
it's not the worst thing a billionaire
has done billionaires what's the worst
thing a billionaire has done
what do you think
God I don't know I mean
probably genocide right oh yeah for sure
that's got to be the top yeah yeah we're
just wiping out massive numbers of
people for your own right business yeah
interests I guess the worst I can find a
billionaire is done is probably pretty
easy to think about it yeah I mean yeah
yeah there's I mean you know
they're not doing enough hilarious stuff
though yeah that's the problem I did
like that the Amazon guy tried to fly
the moon in a penis it should have a
bigger penis yeah and it should have you
know but what the uh what was it called
again that his ship spaceship yeah yeah
like they're not doing a fun bit Bezos
is embracing the villain which I like
he's embracing and he's going listen I'm
bald
I'm taking everybody's jobs now going to
be a drone no matter your aunt worked at
[ __ ] Safeway packing macaroni salad
that's gonna be a robot the Drone is
going to take the macaroni salad your
Thanksgiving pie is going to get
delivered by just like a a predator
drone that's going to drop it to you
nobody's gonna work anymore nobody needs
to I'm going to own all the grocery
stores all the retail stores you're
never gonna have to leave your house
strip malls all that [ __ ] commercial
real estate's gonna tank everything will
be Amazon warehouses I think that's kind
of his vision yeah so you can't be that
guy and also not embrace the yacht the
hoes like embrace it yeah I can't stop
shopping yes his success is kind of
predicated a little bit on everybody you
know kind of losing a job right
everybody you know but it's not villainy
enough man yeah Hazel's building with
your head on it that's a layer there's
this layer that's coming we have layer
he has a layer multiple layers but you
can't like a real nice house with a
couple bricks some of them get weird
weird I want to see Jeff Bezos holding
this like Jesus get Jeff bezos's house
some of them get where you start going
it's a little Tony Stark it's a little I
want some Doctor Doom [ __ ] yeah go
you're a cape I mean some of them are
right there 165 mil up there that house
right there I mean yeah it's still
respect but that's you know that's
you're doing it at that point Jeff Bezos
needs to come out in a black cloak and a
monocle and just go this is who I am now
but here's the thing that we don't want
to we don't want to DARE them to do it
because they will do it that's kind of
fun like that's the thing it's like they
will do it we will see trillionaires In
Our Lifetime yeah we will see people
that have more money and we're already
seeing it than entire gdps of countries
we are gonna see
people we're going to see a level of
luxury that people are living in we're
already seeing space tourism
people going I want to get to space yeah
all the while we're also seeing like a
lot of other crazy [ __ ] happening in the
inner cities where people can't get
clean water you're seeing these guys go
we're kind of tired of this planet yeah
they're that's kind of what they're
doing like all the big billionaires now
they're like listen the the billionaires
in the past weren't great either but
they built railroads they built schools
he said do cool [ __ ] yeah these guys now
are kind of like to be honest we're a
little bored with Earth let's just a
little bored what are we gonna do we're
gonna buy another house in Malibu I know
another house in the Another Hawaiian
island who cares we're bored get us out
of here they're trying to leave the
planet that's what [ __ ] of your planet
they're trying to leave the planet and
listen one of my favorite things is like
they always ask people like they always
bring scientists and all these weird
people together and go where's Climate
Change Gonna head because we want to be
somewhere else yeah so they start
building compounds I know a big real too
says they all want compounds with their
own water aquifiers they want 50 100
acres of land we'll go to Montana
they're all going why do you think you
were going to Montana they're going to
Yellowstone I don't know that who's I
know you're talking about go to Wyoming
billionaires really billionaires they
want space and they want compounds yeah
that's what they're doing that sucks
oh that guy's a [ __ ] yeah I mean
that's that's lairish I mean that's
Hogwarts that's nice it's where he would
live it is a Hogwarts no I want to walk
in it's all like metal you want to raise
her house but this is where Alicia Keys
live go to the razor house razor house
it's in La Jolla in San Diego I know you
yeah she lived there Swiss beats and her
live there go to the razor house this is
where you want them to live look at the
Google image of the Razer house right
here that's what you want the razor
house that's pretty cool like that type
of just Stone and glass Google Mustafar
this is where I want to be this is where
I think Jeff basil should be interesting
m-u-s-d
where is this
Mustafar well you'll see okay
um this is the kind of [ __ ]
this is where people this is where this
is where the Darth Vader lives
it's it's just a lava I forget it how
much of a nerd you are which I love this
yeah yeah so you you were a lava hump a
little lava home that is cold there's no
windows and there's no one else on the
planet yeah just death
but it's like here's what I look at
here's what I think about every now and
then and maybe it's better maybe what
he's doing is better because you walk
into a supermarket and you see somebody
with Down syndrome and you're making
like they're putting the potato salad in
the thing and you say to yourself maybe
they shouldn't have to do this and maybe
Bezos is going to free them from that
right and or you'll see a woman who's
like a hundred she's really old and
they'll be like she's worked here 47
years and we love Irma yeah and and Irma
celebrated her 40th year with the HEB
grocery chain last year she's seen her
kids go to jail and her husband's two
husbands die and she's just still
walking with a hump where she's almost
fully uh uh uh a [ __ ] horseshoe
upside down and she's just walking
around the deli counter and have you
ever asked any of those people for help
because it's sad and it's hard but
sometimes you need to find something and
you ask one of those people for help and
it's literally like they're like oh
and you go hi
do you have any Pepper Jack and they go
and they're just emerging from like this
very scary sad place that you're and
you're like and there because at that
moment they were in like some days and
she's remembering when she could dance
and when the president wasn't black or
whatever and she's she then comes out of
it she goes and then a lot of times
they'll just point she's just gonna
and then she just keeps going and it's
hard so maybe grocery store because some
of the most disturbing things I've ever
seen in my life have been an American
chain grocery stores I have seen things
in a Publix that have should that have
sure I'm a cokehead my mother's a
schizophrenic
um I was a closeted gay guy I was 25 I
was a drunk I had a house at foreclosed
on I was a mess right and all those
things are still in my head and I hung
out and cracked I've seen like people it
not at their best let's just say I've
seen people that are not at their back
sure their mother's still lying in a bed
like out of it and all that [ __ ] and I
deal with it with humor and I try to do
but it's it's [ __ ] up
the things I've seen in a Publix outside
of Orlando
have scared me on a level where like I
go maybe Bezos is it wrong to just get
rid of this right to just eliminate it
to where because the things I've seen
the types of people that just emerge
when you say eliminate you mean uh how
are you it just comes the food just
comes you don't see a guy who's dope I
thought you meant eliminating them as
people I saw a guy in Publix just I
don't mean eliminate them as people but
I saw a guy in the Publix to sunken in
eyes blue he comes out he's still got
his hood you know you see the thing with
their their half dressed like they're
working at the deli counter but then
they also have the hoodie yeah and he
comes in with the hoodie there's a hand
he's tatted up and he's got to put on
the plastic bags yeah honest and you try
not to look at the hands because you go
I don't want to look at those don't
touch my hands you don't want to look at
the things and the arms because there's
things that have happened maybe and he's
just kind of out of it and he's like
what's up man and he's just scooping
stuff and he's trying to weigh it out
and you go like he's like this is this
is tough yeah yeah yeah this is tough
yeah this is tougher because it's his
first job out of rehab yeah it's and
he's still any and he relapsed three
hours ago and he's [ __ ] up
and he's in a Publix and you're staring
at him and you go hey man I'd like this
I'd like that and he's just staring at
you and so some of those things I do
where I see mentally impaired people
working and I go they shouldn't have to
work right and everyone goes no they
like it that's our country it's like
they actually like it gives them a sense
of purpose does does it sure but I've
seen some things in those stores where I
go if that's what he's eliminating
it's okay maybe it's okay maybe everyone
just needs a stipend that can live in
their house nobody really likes jobs I
think food and that [ __ ] should just be
easier to get I mean it's crazy does
anyone want to work at Marshalls does
anyone want to deal with me working
walking in going do you where's the big
and tall and they go I don't know dude
it's a few shirts on the floor find it
or not it's like does anyone want that
gig you know get the robots those jobs I
want a robot to size me up at a [ __ ]
yeah yeah look at this look at this
create a blood-covered man walks into
Florida Publix after stabbing two people
it's where people go when they're at
their lowest point I just found out
about Publix and I really knew about it
yeah I've just been informed of this and
they have a great clubs their sandwich
is fine it's okay people make way too
much out of the Publix Club you know
it's chicken and whatever and sauce they
they put it in a bag they take the
chicken cutlets they cut them off they
put them in a bag with like Ranch and
buffalo sauce and then they shake it and
then a woman like shakes it and then she
pours it onto a very soft bun and rolls
it up and it you know listen it's not
the worst thing in the world but people
really get excited about this and maybe
if Bezos is getting rid of this like
maybe if he doesn't want this anymore
he's like getting rid of them as people
are giving them money so they can
survive you keep saying getting rid of
them as people I'm just confused on what
you're saying he's eliminating them as
like as workers oh okay so so in a good
way Mullen used to always tell me about
this [ __ ] fully luxury automated
communism or whatever where Ubi they all
just Ubi right they all just get look
man shot by Deputy after trying to enter
Green Acres Publix
while armed has died I mean so it's like
it it maybe we don't need this anymore
yeah no I agree maybe it's gotten to a
point where Bezos and his wisdom has
gone how many more stabbings do you want
to see
how many more Trails of blood in the
Frozen aisle do you really want to see
before we're done and if that's the goal
and then also these retail stores lately
I've been listening to a lot of Harry
Potter on audiobook and it's been great
one reason it's been great to listen to
because I use my raycon wireless earbuds
I mean these are perfect they have
optimized gel tips for perfect in-ear
fit they have a 32 hour battery life
eight hours of Play Time Break concert
price just right you get quality audio
and half the price of other audio
premium audio Brands everybody loses the
you know the other ones so you should
have raycons they're cheaper but they
function even better they have three
customizable sound profiles earbud tap
functions noise isolation awareness mode
code so if somebody's coming up behind
you and they want to attack you you know
that that's really important go by
raycon.com Tim today and use my promo
code Tim to get 15 off your raycon order
that's by raycon.com Tim with my code
Tim to score 15 off it is the best deal
you could give them out to people on the
street that are not doing well go down
to Skid Row you see people
they want music they want to listen to
an audio book they don't have you know
it's a great thing to give Christmas is
coming up in three months you know it's
perfect everything about it is perfect
go to buy raycon.com Tim today and use
my promo code Tim to get 15 off that's
by raycon.com Tim with my promo code Tim
to get 15 off by raycon.com Tim
now a word from our sponsor better help
God we've had a long relationship with
better help how you know isn't it
beautiful you have a company to believe
in and you can just work with them talk
about it oh
it could be tough to train your brain to
stay in probing SOB listen here's I'm
not going to read the copy I'm just
going to tell you what it really is
people are sad people are angry people
have problems people are all like this
and what you should do is instead of
like you know trying to do it all on
your own go to go to better help it's
online therapy you can get connected
with a therapist in under 48 hours they
are all great and if you don't like
yours you can change one it's the most
important thing you could do for your
mental health to keep everything's great
I I I love it uh you know better help is
the best option it's convenient
accessible affordable entirely online
you don't have to leave your house
that's where the problems are uh when
you want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there just go to
betterhelp.com slash Tim D to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
better
help.com slash Tim D it's such an
important thing to do people that don't
do it always regret it I'm just a huge
fan of the internet and people talking
to therapists online you don't have to
pull into a parking lot get the ticket
just go and do this therapy online
better help
help.com timd it's very important even
if you don't want the therapy and you
just want to talk to somebody
do that you got a friend I love bespoke
posts because you get the box and you
can give somebody a box and it's the box
of awesome it's got all kinds of stuff
in it no matter what you want you can
get it you just take a quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
each box is valued at around seventy
dollars but you only pay a fraction of
that price plus with each box of awesome
you're supporting small businesses
ninety percent of everything that comes
in your box of awesome is from a small
up and coming brand it's free to sign up
and you can skip a month or cancel
anytime it's great if you know somebody
who's at school or moving somewhere else
it's a way to give them a gift you can
give them every single month it's really
amazing get 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at boxofawesome.com
enter the code Tim Dillon that's box of
awesome.com code Tim Dillon for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com take
the quiz what is that person into are
they an outdoors person do they want
camping stuff and knives or do they want
cookware do they want stuff to make
drinks with e
box of awesome man there's so many cool
things in the box like the Damascus
steel knife is made by Buck bear knives
located in Pennsylvania it's a great
time to have a knife
the multi-tool Gadget from SOG a company
with deep roots in the U.S military
products are regularly field proven by
U.S Special Forces how great is that so
you can have the gadget from SOG SOG and
then you can also because the Special
Forces use it to free people from their
lives
um carnivore
the Box you get American barbecue rub in
the carnivore box I don't even put it on
the meat I like to eat the rub by itself
it's good you can eat it and you can
play with your knife so now go to box of
awesome.com promo code Tim Dylan for 20
off box of awesome.com promo code Tim
Dillon nobody buys any club if you buy
clothes in a store now you're like a
freak
most people buy them online I go to DXL
the fat store it's horrible yeah yeah
it's it's bad and that's why I just
hired a trainer I don't want to go to
that store anymore yeah you see guys are
500 pounds they just they get this big
shirt it's like a 7x it's just like a
tent that goes on them and then it just
has like the Ralph Lauren polo logo that
they've blown up to 7x it's pixelated
it's the biggest Polo you can't even
tell it's a horse you don't know what
kind of animal it is you can't tell it's
a guy in a pores yeah and it's just this
big guy and he's waddling around and
he's always got like some somebody with
them yeah kind of like a wife-ish thing
like a woman there who's like yeah it's
tough yeah yeah it's tough that's why
the fat activist movement like I don't
think fat people should be disrespected
but like it's hard right when I watch a
19 year old kid walk into DXL and he's a
big boy yeah and they're trying to and
and his mom's got there because they're
trying to make him feel good for the
prom and he comes in and he's big and he
knows that prom night's not ending with
[ __ ] he knows that no matter how good
he and the mom will say cute things
she'll be like well this is for the
ladies yeah and he's like listen I have
a rash I have a rash on my inner thigh I
have pustules you know what they are
they're exploding and goo is dripping
down the my thigh and the mom will
always be like you could look good for
the ladies and he's like okay and he's
got this like five acts four accident
it's hard and I know me and you we like
to eat sure but it is difficult so maybe
that short store should not exist yeah
yeah yeah if they could help out that'd
be great it's always a very friendly
like Jamaican woman when I walk and
she's like how you doing I'm like I'm
I'm still here yet let me know if you
need anything oh you look good in that
I'm like no I don't yeah but she's sweet
yeah so maybe it's like instead of
getting mad about Bezos it's like maybe
the things that he's taking away we
would just be better off in our houses
sure yeah maybe not no I I agree I have
nothing more to add you know I don't
know
it's just
it's just like Commerce in America is
not fun right Commerce is not fun
anymore like there's nothing like if
you're hot what's addiction now if
you're hot and Rich everything's fun
yeah you could go to Christian Dior and
they're like
and you go yes but for most people yeah
going out and trying to find anything
it's just not a good time dude I had to
get this outfit for this TV thing I was
doing and everything looked bad because
I'm fat and it was not the jacket I was
like I just don't look at 11 jackets
it's like right you don't it's not the
jacket dude you just gotta get some kind
of sheepskin to cover your whole [ __ ]
body there's a point where and it's just
not a good point in it in the in the
life of a body
where any this shirt right now I have on
doesn't even like it's bunching and
weird and it doesn't like it's like not
there's a time when a body begins to
reject the Garment yeah
the body rejects the Garment the body
goes
no yeah we can't this is a 3X my body
doesn't care
it will not
appropriate way we're not going to help
you look better get your [ __ ] together
man we can't a shirt's not supposed to
be this so they go we've added Fabric
and we've added elastic but it's not
gonna fall on you so the saddest thing
and I've done this is watching fat
people
try to look
good because the clothes themselves just
actually don't work you know who pulled
it off and bring this back and they
don't pull it off because I can't ever
yes do this but you give me a New Jersey
fat [ __ ] Italian yes they have their
look they wear their things they have it
and they do it and there are women that
want that yes not me but I know if I
wear an Adidas tracksuit a cop is going
to come up to me and ask me for a little
of her taste yeah you know what I mean
so I can't do it you know what I mean
but like they they are pulling off fat
there's not a lot okay
billionaire and he can do it but here's
the thing if DJ Khaled couldn't dress
the way he dressed if he had to work at
Geico yeah it's tough
yeah because DXL is not DJ Khaled DXL
it's the fat store I don't know I
remember uh
tall and fat oh no that was uh it's that
yeah yeah it's tall and fat it's all in
fat they call it they used to call it
casual male now they're called DXL bring
that up bring that up
solve for fit by the way expertly
crafted built better design of it solve
for fit it's an equation
this is an equation fat f-i-t look at
this look at this we don't just size up
we size right
and these are by the way even the models
in DXL it's like half of them are dead
some of them are like doing active some
of them are like doing active things but
not really like it'll be three guys
standing by a campfire it's still weird
dude it's it's one of the reasons like
look at that right here is a perfect
example just four morbidly obese guys on
a beach this just passed out just four
really fat guys that decided to start a
bonfire I've never had a fat friend of
mine call me and go let's start a
bonfire on the beach yeah it's like
let's go nowhere near the beach yeah
fully clothed
at DX now I remember DXL my bad my bad
you know what this is I did I do I do of
course I buy my clothes at Target now
yeah that's good too Target you know
that yeah no no that's fine you know but
it's like the experience
for most people yeah in the retail world
yeah it's not fun I just want to go in
and get out yeah you know what I mean
yeah I buy a shirt that looks great I
look at a picture of myself and I go who
let you out of the house it's like old
divorces selling perfume that's fine
it's just you know young foreign women
trying to get you excited the old
department store used to be fun oh it
used to go into a Sears you get a
refrigerator a car stereo yeah you talk
to some guy about a diamond ring it was
great it's all dead now it's all dead
you walk into a place first of all every
Mall you walk into there's a Dick's
Sporting Goods it's massive yeah
you walk through that and then you go to
like some
department store everyone's uptight you
can't sit on anything they start yelling
at you
you know it's you're it's in some
decaying Mall
you Shuffle in you look at you look at a
chair they're like it's 900 I mean it's
just ridiculous I went into a I went
into a Macy's like last week yeah and I
was like I gotta buy a gun
I should just carry a gun for them or
for me for somebody else it's coming
yeah it's all coming I got to defend my
family this is the sign yeah you know
how many you know what I think about DXL
is how many capital Riders you
because that's a real DXL commercial
like how many capital Riders were in DXL
here yeah how many of those guys were
just that's the real commercial right
solve for fit change your country it's
all for the capital what else what else
are you excited about I'm here doing
Cordon I'm doing courting tomorrow how
[ __ ] awesome is that yeah I'm excited
about that that is amazing people say I
have completely given up on my dreams
yes uh they say Don't Stop Believing I
say Stop Believing right once you stop
believing yeah then people go hey now
they do it so just give up on everything
you've always been insanely funny you're
one of the funniest guys to hang out
with oh that's very simple um Everybody
follow you
Friday night Craig of a podcast can I do
that no no of course yeah
oh yeah no I have a podcast Friday night
Greg I I need to start paying for health
care for my kid so if you could listen
to that don't it's not even don't even
listen because you're entertaining by it
no just know that a child because it's
the right day care it's the right listen
it's the right thing to do there's a kid
and if you're ever in town I'd love to
have you come on no I'm going to be in
town we also don't have to come do it
either I just like to be around I'd love
to be honest I'm in town more often now
yeah down here in New York we'll do it
but now I agree with Bezos a little bit
now where it's like all right
as long as the people are given money
yeah the people are giving money because
I think if you told that old woman it's
on us
I saw a guy come out of it it was I was
a Stop and Shop and he came out I have a
distinct memory of this I was like six
or seven he comes out he had
elephantiasis or Titus out of his face
Horrible no he had like a giant elephant
tusk right and the manager came running
and went you gotta go back and like
threw him back into the like he was like
cutting meat or whatever he was like a
thing and I remember being like it was
horrifying for me but then also the
knowing now it's like Yeah man they
would force they wouldn't let that guy
leave the cold storage of the amp what
did he want to do just bleed out just
wanted to see humans oh he wanted to see
people he came out bleed out I thought
he was just gonna like make a laceration
try to drain his head
that's the one of the worst diseases is
there's elephantitis yeah that's rough
any complaint you have in life right is
immediately imagine but that's maybe why
we need to keep these doors open so you
can go and see people with elephantitis
and right things are fine and the thing
too is the more you see them I used to
think that's uh midgets is that not the
right word I don't know I apologize yeah
so none other guys little fellas it says
Bros
we just call them Bros I used to be like
weird but the more they got in the
comedy and the more you see people
around now I'm seeing hot ones and I'm
like ah [ __ ] a bunch of these you know
what I mean like you just need to see
more of all this you're married now so
well that's why I'm like in prison I
look out yeah I will [ __ ] anything not
not literally do it right but of course
yeah no there are there are there are
did you look up hot [ __ ] we got them
looking up hot midgets smoking hot no
there's tons of little people that are
very attractive right you just gotta get
used to it I didn't like Asians they
have a DXL and I don't know what it is
but I want to find it like they
absolutely have a DXL there's got to be
a little bit
oh there's a tiny XL I'd like to argue
that uh uh I just said uh I used to not
like Asians and didn't get to finish
this episode I'm sorry so I just threw
that into the world no no no keep going
keep keep going I didn't even hear it
only because what was it about them the
organized it seemed organized no but I
met my wife and then all of a sudden
right I started seeing eight now they're
all so hot to me you have to be around
you have to open your eyes I met my wife
and then I started seeing Asians I never
saw them before and then you open your
eyes
well you were Greg carluzzo yeah he
didn't like it Greg cart luzo doesn't
explosions married one Greg stone is a
is a father of an Asian baby kind of
right kind of no yes is where my son is
Asian where is the social media people
to follow you uh you follow me on
Instagram Greg F Stone Greg F Stone yeah
Greg Epstein just type if you just type
Greg Stone comedian yes that's how you
get it you know in Google you know what
I mean yes very good I appreciate it
we'll see you soon I'm going to Romania
but then we'll be back thank you folks
good night